[Music]
you're doing that cake yeah why we spit
in it you good
yeah what's been in that cake anyway
this story has nothing to do with cakes
okay that was a good set of a segue yeah
yeah well has nothing to do with it okay
who comes in the cake we wake up with
[ __ ] in our bed again no so this time
imagine the kind of mess that me imagine
go and make math messed up
don't imagine what the story's about
all right come on so this guy named
Lucia Delgado
that's are you funny no missing all
right so he has he has studied and done
everything by the book to become an
American citizen
oh no and he went to go get like his
interview and everything and when he was
taking the test the final thing that he
needed to do in order to pass was
favorite movie was to read a sentence in
English oh she wasn't able to why he
should have learn how to read English
well the thing is he is completely blind
oh we didn't have Braille for him to
read so what they like what's wrong are
you blind
you can't hey pal it's a top line what
the hell's wrong with you top line so
I'm blind good like duh that's why you
can't read I'm gonna play a little video
clip to speed
Lucy Lucy oh so you guys can see his
status and how he feels about this and
all of that are we gonna see a blind guy
cry no you know blind guy cried
here we go wasn't able to believe I was
actually Stephanie in American soil
I was excited beyond belief and I was
astonished over here I was going to
obtain the education I couldn't get in
Mexico
really laughs Korea was good to be here
and they're proud I have to prove that
I'm blind
even though they have the accommodations
form and they had my state ID in record
they still didn't believe that I was
blind but everything has to be you know
spoken by a piece of paper you speaks
[ __ ] good ass English is better than
some Americans else do they need from it
almost every American I know including
you guys yeah that's true
he has more of a work range he's
probably listening to JK news is like oh
yeah I know what that means Steve you're
not alone so he learned English by
listening to the radio and that's when
you know he he came to the United States
he was ready to pass that test but like
I said they were not they said like
there was no chance of passing because
of the fact that he couldn't read I
didn't for who was the [ __ ] dumbass at
that
so the thing is that they said that they
need to get a doctor's note telling him
that he is legally blue because oh okay
so what they think okay I get it
Wow yeah yeah he could be lying you
can't fake eyes like that
but the thing is that Lucy yeah well
dude we've done some stories on Jackie
where guys have dressed this week guys
have dresses chicks and been pretty
convincing and [ __ ] and they still you
know remember the medical insurance one
or whatever no the insurance front one
with a guy dressed like his mom medical
but driver's license yeah the driving
test yeah take a test like as his mom
and Nicki was passing like you just
don't know what people are willing to do
yeah but like but I agree I don't
[ __ ] I don't know how you could I
like how they're using this as evidence
like look at his poker he's obviously
black he has a white cane and all that
but so the thing is that we'll see oh he
doesn't have health insurance so he
can't go see a doctor to get verified so
there's like the red tape around that
now and he just feels like his dreams
have been crushed and he's pretty he
could play again right just got a wait a
little bit not he's looking into getting
an immigration attorney to help appeal
this because how much is it can we just
like crowd for like yeah bucks or
something it goes out there get a [ __ ]
yeah three semi all you got and you
don't you have to go to a medical doctor
right you got to go to like a Thomas
Druce are they done with just I don't
know they're just that doctor I just
went to a [ __ ] doctor to get I mean
me and icky had bronchitis this is like
two months ago
you peed like 800 bucks just sit in the
room and for them to be like yeah we
think you got bronchitis
with or without insurance that that was
with insurance $800 how much is your
monthly for the both of you so [ __ ] it's
like Urgent Care knows cheap it's a lot
it's a lot it's a lot was that including
the descriptions of all that stuff my
urgent care was do you know now that doc
Ewing prescriptions so yeah it was 250
but I paid $65 yeah yeah yeah did health
net sucks don't get health nut sucks ass
get BlueShield
but then again i'm paying like 400 bucks
a month so you know who's really losing
here three years and really go for like
the yearly thing and that's it all
American healthcare suck yeah yeah
really bad socks too damn expensive it's
not worth it just don't get sick don't
go see it worse - man it's gotten worse
see God more expensive and they cover
less yeah maybe you guys just got richer
no no this guy's just got worse yeah I
had the exact same plan and for the last
two years has gone up a hundred dollars
every year that's crazy it's gone up
like 150 percent year-over-year I think
it's crazy for um for Chi Asuka she
comes from Canada it's like free health
care right so she's like she's used to
just whenever she's feeling any type of
a little bit of sick should go to the
doctor just to make sure she's okay now
she's here she's like bro what what is
happening on you that's why I never go
to the doctor I heard over there you
gotta wait a long time though you might
wait like 12 hours hmm I mean it's not
12 hours she would definitely be like
hey I want to get something checked out
so I'm gonna go like you know she would
definitely have to wait for a few hours
it wasn't like all day but at the same
time it was you know it's hurry serious
has she had like an issue though because
out here I've heard no no no in Canada
cuz I've heard that an MRI can take
months like that's what I've heard I
don't know yeah I'm asking you I don't
know what she hasn't had any serious
issues and you know we're good we just
got into the whole like you know she's
on my healthcare now so uh Nick Cannon
health can sag I'm on set I get sag
health care but you know that's really
good health care though ya know it's so
dear
the best [ __ ] I've ever seen is it Nikki
was on him like three years ago in his
[ __ ] dough
oh okay last time in a SAG video people
didn't know people were confused as to
where was the Screen Actors Guild it's a
it's a union I thought you were talking
[ __ ] about a certain group they fell
people that sag or Saget IDEO ladies yes
and then you're in so now like she's a
part of that health care and like you
know I'm going to the doctor for the
first time in like a couple years soon
and then there's like a poll that they
did of every every country's health care
system and how the people who live there
feel about it and every country has like
a rating system that they consider like
it's all less than 50% like even like
some of the best countries for health
care they have like forty forty two
percent forty three percent no one likes
their health nobody loves their health
care like were they like I [ __ ] love
this [ __ ] yeah we have the worst though
when it comes to look like the bottom
bottom of the barrel for sure
but look when it comes to the poll but
it's fascinating to see like there is no
place where no one's happy about it I'm
annoying everywhere I'm not even yeah I
never heard a person go my country's the
superior issed
right I feel like Japan would be pretty
awesome I guess they don't get sick out
there they just live until their legs my
grandparents and my mom loves the
Taiwanese health care so like as soon as
they could establish my citizenship that
they did that just saw that since she's
married to me she's also a time when he
citizen now word if she lame she breaks
her leg and we can't afford it here we
can go your Taiwanese citizen yeah your
Taiwanese did you have to pay for
anything in Canada ever like medically I
don't think so cuz I've heard that
there's some kind of a copay system so
so not maybe not maybe not in Canada I
don't know but I've heard that in a lot
of these countries where we think you
can just walk in and there's no copay
nothing there there is some kind of a
little bit great but I'm just saying I'm
just saying to dispel the myth that
people have we just walk in and they're
like okay bye
like I think she made like Ali like I
don't see her paying more than like 20
bucks in Canada when she was going in
for stuff but you know in some countries
that's undisclosed you can bring a
bottle whiskey to make sure that doctor
do malpractice on you and you bribe them
oh you like handed to them and if you
don't give it to them they do
malpractice no I mean like it's kind of
like insurance for them to pay extra
attention into you because they'll
half-ass their work yeah and bribing is
a part of the culture I mean driving is
a part of in undisclosed okay I heard
that if you want your flight attendant
and completely off-topic
I heard that take a plane so take extra
care of you you just bring her like a
little pack of M&Ms or like some candy
some chocolate no I did it once did you
yeah anyway you can bring you know extra
water and I bet that happened to Jeana
she brought it in and then dig knows
Julia oh and you were okay she's not
Asian Oh married to a Japanese no but
yeah they ended up getting upgraded to
no so that's good then yeah but it's get
out from me personally myself it did not
work oh maybe the chocolates sucked kind
of chocolate but these what is it can be
hard to be a US citizen though I think
they only let him let in like 60,000 a
year that's crazy what not every year
it's yeah it's a you're allowing
official citizenship but they give out
like visas they give out green cards and
whatever but to become and match like an
actual citizen it's sixty thousand for
country that has three hundred million
people that's all that's a very small
number here's what you do you marry
someone you marry someone No
so struggle are you have a kid you may
have fat ugly white dude uh-huh you
gotta be in the country for 90 days and
hopefully at that time you've made his
super evangelical family mm-hmm
comfortable enough with you easy yeah
but you got to be together I've got to
be together for like a couple years
though did you know that how
so it takes 90 days to actually do them
be careful plan is Saturday for they
come do checkups on you and you have to
stay together for a couple of years
extras of videos right as it depends it
depends it depends if that's a song
isn't it
what it depends it Abed today any fans
their family depends if you you know you
can do it two ways right you can either
go through the whole process
get your 90-day visa first and then get
married and then they will ask you a
couple questions or you can do it the
more risky way which is you just get
married in Vegas or something like that
and then you have to prove that your
marriage is real then that's a little
more like they scrutinize you a little
more is that what you did no no I did it
where we went through the whole process
got the 90-day fiance visa then we got
married while she was here on that visa
and then and and and that's what we did
yeah so do you don't have any stigma for
marrying an immigrant perfectly good
white girls here have you seen that the
girls out here bro fire big titties
tight round asses what the [ __ ] you
absolutely you're in LA like one of the
hottest places on earth for women have
you been [ __ ] doc Dunkin Donuts
around Canadian girls are where it's a
bro really Wow hello we're good say what
now they're both North American guys all
got the last good one
no no American chicks is worth that huh
you disgust that Timmy just because you
found that got a tractive Lumberjacks
daughter doesn't mean everyone you're
gonna Canadian girls are pretty cool
because they are you should I get laid
tonight T is not even watching this you
don't watch this okay fired Kendricks
are anti head
[Music]
[Music]